[Music]
okay thank you so much to J's calm for
having me here I'm so excited this is my
first time to Europe at all so I'm
having a great time in Berlin thanks to
Ben Schwartz for your talk before mine
because you said a lot of things that I
didn't have time to say in 25 minutes
for mine so anyone who stayed for that
talked and stayed for mine you have some
good context for what I'm going to talk
about today and so this talk was
actually inspired by offline camp so
offline kimberlyn happened last weekend
I got to attend that one but I attended
two more before that and I talked to a
lot of people who were doing really
amazing things in the offline first base
and learned about a lot of really
amazing projects that are impacting
people's lives and so that's what this
talk is about but first I kind of wanted
to give a little overview of what
offline first is and really the main
tenets of this is that offline should
not be treated as an error condition
this is a state you should be planning
for and expecting from your users so the
place that it kind of came from is that
you know if you think about mobile first
as a movement we move from designing
applications for the desktop to mobile
first because we wanted to design for
the most constrained environment and
that's kind of a thought behind offline
first we want to treat the offline state
as the most constrained environment
start there and then move on from that
to progressively enhance the application
as you get connectivity so when we think
about bad offline States some bad
examples this is kind of what you see
here on your app you lose connectivity a
window pops up blocks you from what you
were doing and tells you how your
offline
you don't know if what you are doing is
lost you don't know if you lost content
you have no idea if you can continue
doing what you were in the middle of
doing when you lost connectivity this is
a really bad experience for your user
Flipkart has a really good example of
this this is their a hugely popular
e-commerce site in India and when they
lose connectivity you can see it's very
clear wherever you are in the site the
site turns gray and it lets you know hey
you're offline and because it doesn't
block anything you kind of assume okay I
didn't lose where I am when I go back to
connectivity I'll be able to pick up
where I left off and that's pretty good
experience Tonga takes it a step further
so they recently switched to offline
first and when you first launch the app
for the first time lets you know hey if
you lose connectivity we have some of
your data and you can continue to do
some things offline and then in the
second screenshot you see in offline
mode it lets you know you can still view
in order recently view product you can
see your saved items and you can still
do some things with your cart and that's
pretty cool housing comm is a retail
around a real estate site in India very
popular and when you lose connectivity
with that you lets you know you're
browsing an offline mode which the word
browsing kind of lets you know you can
continue doing things and offline
anything that's been cached anything
we've done before and if you navigate to
your favorites you see that you didn't
lose any of the listings that you
favorited in that section in that
session so that's a really good
experience it grades out it's really
obvious that you can't do a whole lot
but unless you know you didn't lose
anything you were in the middle of doing
so now I want to tell you a little bit
more about how often first is actually
changing lives and maybe even saving
them and you the JavaScript community
are doing a really amazing things in
this space so you just Pat yourselves on
the back because you already offline
first and you may not even know it but
these projects are really cool so why we
will use technology that's built for Los
Angeles and London when we live in New
Delhi and I would Roby this is the CEO
eric Hirschman
BRIC out of adversity can come
innovation so imagine that you live in a
refugee camp and if you have small
children you want to be able to continue
to teach your children and have full
daily lives as you you know figure out
what your next step is going to be BRIC
allows you to continue to run your
classrooms you have curriculum that's
managed remotely and your teachers are
allowed to make changes to this
curriculum and then changes are kind of
remotely brought down from educators
around the world that contribute and
BRIC nice is possible it's a local micro
server that stores correcting them
locally and then as I said it's remotely
managed so it's dustproof its rugged is
solar-powered and it's sort of a
built-in Wi-Fi hotspot and you can sync
your content using the brick cloud and
then enjoy your classrooms working
stephensi even in low latency or no
connectivity at all so you might
remember in Haiti there was a horrible
earthquake that devastated the country
in 2010 and in 2014 70% of the country
still did not have any electricity
this was a huge improvi ously but the
country relied pretty heavily on
agriculture and they the farmers were
not able to make the same profits off of
their crops because they couldn't access
electricity to process the vegetables
and you know kind of get that ready for
shipment to leave so they lost millions
of dollars and the economy was really
you know pretty devastated but not only
that just normal families couldn't
access electricity to take care of their
children so with access to the right
technology they could rebuild those
micro grids within their communities and
get electric goods back running spark
meter did this they were founded in 2013
and they offer comprehensive low cost
metering solutions for everything from
rural micro grids you know out in small
villages to existing urban central you
know grid utilities
and now they support grids in 15
countries adding more every day so they
have a JavaScript front-end and they use
symmetric D s to handle sinking on when
the app is online and then rabbitmq and
celery to handle an asynchronous casting
for energy billing meter processing and
payments so this kind of brings me to
one of the first challenges I'm going to
talk about three in this talk offering
first is still a developing concept and
there are a lot of problems still need
to be solved and the first one that I
want to talk about is sinking so the
sink conflicts are hard and it's hard to
handle that when we think about Brinks
bricks sinking capabilities or spark
meter you know sending bills out to use
families in rural parts of Haiti you
want to make sure you're got you've got
it right and you're not overwriting data
or processing wrong data for people so
there's a few ways that you can do take
care of this one solution is CouchDB
it's a JavaScript database with this
ability to sync with anything that
implements the Clow are the CouchDB
replication protocol it allows you to
read and write data directly on to the
device and then sync this data when
you're back in connectivity this also
includes IBM Cloudant which is a fully
managed cloud database that is based on
CouchDB so this is another solution you
can utilize for syncing so back to Kenya
this picture is a bunch of doctors who
are loading patient records on to a bus
to drive out to a village pretty far
away from the hospital the this is how
they were handling you know all their
patient records and you can imagine you
know it's one hundreds of pounds of
paper that is very vulnerable to the
elements and this is not a sustainable
way to make sure you're saving lives of
people that really really need your help
and before hospital run came along they
were really relying on this process so
this application came along
they Hospital run did a lot of research
and they found that 20% of health care
professionals time is spent just on
administrative tasks and a lot of that
time is spent by the software they were
using so you they were taking all these
papers out to a village making all these
changes to the patient records in the
history and then they had to go back and
manually enter all of that data into
their software and their software was
crappy to begin with so it took a lot of
time hospital run made it possible for
them to take the patient records out
with a tablet or a mobile phone and
because they were able to do that they
could make changes while they were
offline out in the village and then the
changes would sync when they got back
into Wi-Fi available when they were back
at the hospital hospital run uses ember
and posh DB for the front end and then
node and CouchDB on the back end and
because it's built using an offline
first progressive web app it works when
there's no end of internet and then
syncs when there is now in the Yukon of
Alaska healthcare workers really wanted
a better way to be able to take care of
pregnant mothers and their newborn
babies because these people were you
know rural poor they live pretty far
from hospital in depending on the time
of year it might have been impossible to
get there if an emergency happened and
Yukon doesn't have great mobile coverage
and because these people really had to
think about you know keeping their costs
low making sure that application was
lightweight and didn't drive up a lot of
mobile data usage was really important
so Yukon baby was built and this is an
application that gets vital information
out to new mothers it's built with
angularjs and node and you IBM Cloudant
sync which lets your users work offline
and then just think data when the
connection is available so using cloud
and also keeps cost low to the users
because it only updates when there is
new information if you had so it keeps
mobile bills Wells to for these people
which is awesome now this brings me to
the next real problem with offline first
that still needs some attention when an
application
cassia's data locally to a device you
really have to think about the privacy
concerns around the data that you're
saving so you need to think about how
this is handled and whether you know
when you're thinking about Hospital
information medical history all that
kind of stuff someone who's pregnant
doesn't want people to know that they're
pregnant yet
you want to make sure that best
information is not being shared when it
needs to be private so when you're
thinking about security with offline
applications you really have to think
about data validation offering the
ability to log out so that if you're
sharing a device to someone else that
information isn't shareable once you log
out of that and for apps that require
really high security you might want to
consider end end encryption encryption
for your app so writing secure apps is
hard and even harder in the browser
Calvin NetCast is here at the conference
I think today he wrote a really cool
post on the offline camp medium account
about security from a session that we
had so I encourage you to check out that
medium account and read that because a
lot of good information so you might be
thinking now what about me I'm talking
about people who live in rural areas or
developing countries you might not be
designing apps for these kinds of users
and you might think you know what why
does this apply to me what kinds of
things are more relatable to what I deal
with on a daily basis well I'm from the
US and I am concerned about my current
president and the administration there
and that project came along and they
wrote a really simple application that
makes it easier for governments and
researchers to share their data sets
with software developers to do really
useful things so their grant funded and
it's decentralized
it's a sharing tool for efficiently
versioning and then syncing these really
big data sets and it can be used to
version the data locally and then share
and sync it over the Internet
and it's open source so you can check it
out and you know see what they're doing
and it's built with nodejs
so by taking an offline first approach
to digital preservation this tool really
allows researchers to easily share
all these really huge data sets in a
really lightweight way and before this
they were really doing it very manually
they were using you know spending a lot
of money on Dropbox or doing really
manual you know here's a giant flash
drive of information please don't drop
it in water kind of thing you know that
makes it really simple for these people
to share data across the globe that's
really touval and like I said in the US
we had an issue where in January the
White House gov deleted all the open
datasets that were available and maxes
out Ogden who is one of the people who
works at that project tweeted I already
grabbed it so you can come and get it
which was awesome because we thought it
was lost forever
and the next thing under threat for us
really is the Environment Protection
Agency's climate change data we want to
make sure this information is preserved
for future generations to prove as these
things are true because it's very
important so you can go to the DAP
project website and see a lot of these
datasets that they have available and
it's accessible for you to do anything
you want build all kinds of applications
to using it so how do you convince your
boss and your company and your team to
invest in the extra time to make your
app offline first there are some really
convincing reasons and then actually
pointed out a lot of them in regard to
performance so when we look at Elte
capacity the capacity has remained the
same in the US over the last 12 months
but the number of users and the amount
of bandwidth per user has increased
dramatically because of things like
video streaming entertainment video
conferencing and action of stuff so this
is all resulted in the past year from
year to year a 50 percent slow slowing
of the speeds overall and the u.s. is 20
percent slower than Europe actually and
so this is something that if your users
are predominantly in the US or Europe
you really have to think about how the
performance of your app is not only that
but sixty percent of the world is on 2g
on a 2g network and when you're thinking
about the developing world two-thirds of
that
are using a to 2g network so if you're
only building your application to work
and it's the best-case scenario these
people may not have even be able to
access it not only that but a 4G user
isn't a 4G user most of the time even in
your best case scenario people live in
variable connectivity they take the
subway to work they take trains they
take buses they walk in between
skyscrapers and lose connectivity you
don't want people to try to access your
app in that moment and then lose them
because as we all know you lose 40% of
your users if it takes three more than
three seconds for your app to load even
aside from that radio cell towers
preserve power by sort of transitioning
between high and low states so whatever
a given point if your user tries to
access your app they might be accessing
at during that low period of sort of
power gridding and then you lose them
because the app took too long to load so
by designing for low latency first
you're making really substantial for
from improvements in performance so it's
really imperative that you design your
apps for performance and really being
able to get baselines through in spite
of low connectivity is really really
important so let's go back to flip art
this is an example I mentioned earlier
so when they switch to an offline first
app they did a few things to really
increase the speed of their application
they added a splash screen they switch
to using service workers so they could
handle notifications they you know sort
of added smoother animations to their
site and because of that they had three
times less data usage overall they had a
40% higher engagement rate they increase
their conversion by 70% and overall the
users spend more time on it on their
platform which for an e-commerce site is
really what you want you want people
shopping so this brings me to one more
challenge I want to talk about in regard
to offline first design patterns are
still being invented there isn't really
one way that users are used to seeing
and experiencing the offline state in
applications there's no standard
of us so this is something that still
needs to be developed by the community
Steve Travis on who is one of the
organizers of offline camp and is the
founder of make and model co-wrote a
really amazing post about design
patterns for offline states and he kind
of had three tenets that he talked about
freshness reach and assurance so when we
talk about freshness we're thinking
about you know how fresh is the data how
are you communicating the freshness of
data to your users so you could
communicate this in a lot of different
ways and we've all probably seen it you
can say you know here's a timestamp of
the last time your data was updated it
was last viewed on this day there is an
update available so refresh your app
that kind of thing when we're looking at
reach we want to know is the data
reachable or is it not and that should
be really clearly communicated so you
know is it clear that I can perform an
action right now or is it really obvious
that I need to wait until I'm in
connectivity to be able to do this so
like checking out your cart of items
that you want to buy that kind of thing
an assurance is when we're talking about
that we're thinking about how much is my
responsibility as a user to save the
data that I have so when I lose
connectivity do I have the
responsibility to save what I'm writing
or is the app going to take care of that
for me
and we've all experienced this where we
write a really long paragraph of text in
a form we click send lose connectivity
and then we lose the whole thing we
wrote I'm going to start over that sucks
we don't want that we want to do that to
our users so you really want to think
about you know how are you to
communicate this from the browser is
there a Save button
is it still saving does it is it in the
middle of syncing should I wait those
kinds of things let your user know that
it's worth waiting for because it's
going to happen at some point so this is
really still a problem that we need your
help to solve and this is what the
JavaScript community you know this is
there's so many opportunities for you to
still contribute so please go to offline
first org because this is where you can
connect with the offline first community
there's a slack organization which is
very active
and you can actually talk to all the
people who are involved with all the
projects that I discussed and offline
camp is really cool it's a really fun
unconference way for you to contribute
to the community talk about the things
that you're doing because the community
really wants to hear what you're doing
and what what you're contributing
already and how these problems might
already be solved out there and so yeah
we really want to hear what you're doing
please connect the best thanks to
Patricia Garcia if you attended James
Caan's last year then you may have seen
her talk that was a good text for hard
places fighting Ebola with JavaScript
offline apps that it was about a Health
Africa which is another really amazing
offline first project that you should
look into and then I've also included a
plethora of really nifty nifty tools
that you can use if you want to research
offline first including also a lot of
further reading for the articles that I
read in preparation for this talk and
you can also access them on my slides
they should be tweeted right now I think
HootSuite did that for me but you can
get them through this link here but
thank you so much that's all I have
today
[Music]
you